أستطيع أن أقول لراقصتي أن ألتقي بأناس جدد
يستمتعون بأشياء جديدة وبالطبع Winkle
miliore أفضل واحد سيفوز
[موسيقى]
اسمي إنريكي بارباغالو أنا
مصمم رقصات أنا إيطالي لقد استدرت عمليًا
نصف العالم بأسلوب
كلاسيكي وحديث  الموت المعاصر
مؤخرًا ، كنت أعمل مع FIFA
أيضًا ، لقد قمت بعمل مقطع فيديو
لأول مرة في الواقع أقوم
بأحداث
المتطوعين في قطر في
المدرج الذي كان لدي 30 راقصًا آخر
حدث كان في منطقة المرح  لقد
تعاونت في الحفلة الموسيقية مع
الجنيات المتوسطة وقالت مالوما إنني بدأت عندما كنت
في التاسعة من عمري كراقصة
وواصلت مرارًا وتكرارًا ووصلت إلى
سن حيث وإلى نقطة
قررت فيها أنني أريد إنشاء شيء ما
لا أريد فقط أن أتبع
مصممي الرقصات الآخرين وأن أرقص مثلما
طلبوا مني أن أرقص ، أريد أن أصنع
شيئًا يخصني وأنه
فريد لأنني أعتقد أن أسلوبي
في تصميم الرقصات
يختلف قليلاً عن الآخرين وهذا هو  ماذا او ما  لقد
فعلت ذلك بالفعل ، لذلك بدأت العمل مع
راقصين مختلفين لإيجاد أسلوب
جديد ومزاج جديد والعمل على تعبيرات الجسد التي
كنت
أعلمها على خشبة المسرح والتي كانت
قوية جدًا والتي جلبتني إلى الدوحة
وإلى  في الواقع ، أقوم بعمل الكوريغرافيا
المتعلقة بتعبير جسدي بشكل أساسي ، فإن
الكوريغرافيا مختلفة جدًا ، إنه تحد كبير
كان علي تغيير كل المزاج
الذي يمر عبر الثقافة في محاولة
لفهم الثقافة والدين
وكل شيء ووضع المشاعر
معًا في معظم تصميم الرقصات الخاص بي  أعتقد
أن الأغنية تختلف عن غيرها ،
لذا أحاول التعبير عن
مشاعر الأغنية نفسها من خلال الحركات ،
فكل ممثل مباشر لديه
طلب مختلف بأسلوب مختلف
ومزاج مختلف ويجب أن تكون قادرًا على متابعة
عقولهم وعقليتهم و
ما يريدونه وأحيانًا يطلبون
منك عمل تصميم رقص وأثناء
التصوير يغيرون كل شيء
ويريدون منك إعادة التشغيل وتعيد
ذلك  يجب أن تكون
قويًا جدًا وسريعًا للتعامل مع
المخرج ، وهذا أمر مهم جدًا ،
إنه لأمر مدهش أنه تحد كبير ،
ويبدو حقًا أنه
نجاح كبير حققوه
كثيرًا ، وأعتقد أنهم
يقومون بعمل رائع.  وظيفتي
وشخصيًا أشعر أيضًا أنني لا أعرف أن العالم بأسره
يعمل ،
فنحن جميعًا جميع الأشخاص من
مصممي الرقصات جميع الراقصين الذين أتيحت لهم
الفرصة للمشاركة في العديد من
الأحداث لدي الكثير من الرقصات هناك  في
كل مقطع الفيديو ، لذلك كانت
فرصة كبيرة للجميع أن يفعلوا
شيئًا مختلفًا ليكونوا جزءًا من
العالم ، لذلك أعتقد أنه من
المدهش أن يكون لدي رسالة
لمن سيأتي اليوم
إلى الدوحة للاستمتاع أه لتجربة
تجربة جديدة للقاء أشخاص جدد يستمتعون
بأشياء جديدة وبالطبع وينكل ميليوري
أفضل شخص سيفوز ، هذا جيد ، إنه
مكاني المفضل كما يقول الجميع
رونالدو ولكني كنت
أتابعها منذ وقت طويل  إن إيطاليا ليست
في كأس العالم ، لذا فأنا لا أعرف حقًا من
سأدعمه ولكن أه رونالدو بالتأكيد
رونالدو نعم
[موسيقى]